[Music]
good
chrisan
[Music]
e
you
[Music]
TR
was
[Music]
for
ch
[Music]
e
got third place
of
Jo
baptism so we're going to have baptism
here on suay January
[Music]
Ann
service
not yet not yet soon
soon I said soon
soon
no
don't
as
performer
come yourself you're not forced to beone
you're unfort and
know heav father I thank you first and
for all the people get
here and for ours that
areow
us
and
[Music]
AC
amen thanks maram if you guys want to
stand we're going to start off with
music and um if you are new to this
community I see a couple new faces I
just want to apologize in advance
because a couple people have pointed out
that me and my twin sister both have on
beanies and flannel shirts and jeans and
gray shoes so that wasn't intentional we
were not trying to throw anyone off or
make it more difficult but uh you're not
seeing double there are two of us and
I'm sorry
so but I'm Mindy this is Gary and Jenny
Lee and Maggie and we want you guys to
be a part of the worship set um whether
you're on this stage or on that side of
it um this is an all play so you guys
join in as you
can
[Music]
you broke my chains of sin and shame and
you cover me
[Music]
with you are the hand that reaches out
to
say I am set free
oh I am set free oh
W it is for
Freedom that I am set
[Music]
fre you broke my chains of sin and shame
and you covered me with
gra you made my
you're Holy Fire you cover me with
Grace you are the hand that reaches out
to
say I am set
free I am set fre
[Music]
oh it is for
Freedom that I I am set
free I am set free
oh I am set free
oh it is for
[Music]
Freedom that I am
set yes Lord we are grateful for your
grace and For Your
Love Yes Lord we are grateful for your
gra and For Your
Love Yes Lord we are
grateful for your grace and for your
love you are the hand that reaches out
to
say I am set free
oh I am set free
oh
it is for
Freedom that I am set
[Music]
free I am set free
oh I am set free
oh it is for
freedom and I am set free
[Music]
I'm set
free
[Music]
we're set
free
[Music]
free we're set
free
[Laughter]
free I am set set free
oh I am set free
oh it is for
Freedom that I
am
free I am set free
oh I am set free
oh
it is for
Freedom that I am set
[Music]
free all right kiddos you guys are
dismissed to go to your classes we have
second suit through sixth over
here and to my left we have preschoolers
Toddlers and our
Nursery
thank you kids ministry workers so much
we love you guys thanks for loving on
our
kids we are going to go ahead and move
into the prayers of the people and if
this is your first time it's um an
opportunity for us to lift up before God
and our community the things that we're
carrying into this space whether it's a
person that's on your heart or a
situation that that's um concerning you
or that you're carrying um we're going
to read through this prayer aloud
together and then leave some space for
us to each say allow the thing um that's
on our hearts that we want to lift
before God and then we'll end the prayer
together again so would you guys read
this aloud with me for the city of saxi
Texas and for every city and community
and all who live in them we pray to you
for the Good Earth you have given given
us and the wisdom and the will to
conserve it we pray to you for the old
and the sick for the Widow and orphan
for the injured and suffering we pray to
you for the poor and the oppressed the
unemployed and destitute for prisoners
and captives and all who remember and
care for them we pray to you for the
vulnerable the marginalized and those
unjustly targeted for their gender
sexuality race or other perceived
difference we pray to you for those
experiencing loss loneliness and
disconnection and for those struggling
with mental and emotional health we pray
to you Lord we know that you love us and
that you hear us so we lift these names
and situations up to
you
[Music]
for broken
familyes for the names and the moments
that we have spoken aloud and for those
that we have kept in our hearts we pray
to you that they may have life and light
healing and hope peace and a deep sense
of your
presence
[Music]
amen
stand
[Music]
together
together For Your
Glory
and
[Music]
for I walk
through I
see
I
[Music]
hased work
together for my
future and for my good you make all
things
work
together for your
glory and for your
[Music]
name
all
things work
together my
future and for my good you make all
things work
together for your
glory and for your
name I'm wonderfully made you're an
artist and a I'm the canvas and the CL I
know nothing has been wasted no failure
or mistake you're an
arst I'm the C stand
the you're
fin you're fin with me
[Music]
not
good would you me how
[Music]
reste will you build fold By the Waters
that
refes will
[Music]
call from my
anxious to lab on and
on from the Restless grind that has put
my mind to
sleep will you call me back and gently
Slow Me
Down Will you show me now what to lose
and what to
keep oh good
shepher oh good
friend slow me
down slow me
down oh good
shepher oh good
friend Slow Me
Down Slow Me
[Music]
Down
here with what truly
sisf oh good
shepher oh good
friend Slow Me
Down Slow Me
Down oh good
shepher oh good
friend Slow Me
Down Slow Me
Down
Street
[Music]
maketing
Fe oh good
shepher oh oh good
friend Slow Me
Down Slow Me
Down oh good
shepherd oh good
friend Slow Me
Down Slow Me
[Music]
God would you slow down our
minds our
hearts that run ahead and worry and
stress and get
anxious our tendency to grasp and
control and
manipulate
God would you help us to open our
hands to T trust that you really do make
things work together for the good of
those who love
you and that can be so hard to believe
God when we look around at our pain and
our
mess when we know our own Brokenness our
own Tendencies to hurt ourselves or the
people around
us it can be hard to trust that you can
weave together something out of all of
that
chaos out of all of that
pain but God would you help us to open
up our hearts and our hands and let you
do your good work in
us would we believe that there is more
to the story that there is hope
ahead that there will be
a new day with new
promises with new
[Music]
mercies God and where we can't hold that
space for ourselves would we hold it for
each
other would we believe for one
[Music]
another there is
good there is a God who loves us and is
for us and is with us in this season
Emmanuel came to be with
[Music]
us thank you
God for that constant
presence would we rest in
it in Jesus name
amen thank you guys would y all turn to
the people around you say hello make
them feel welcome and then we'll get
started on our
message and
peace it is so good to be with you my
name is Brett and
a joy joy to be in this
SP
espe you are not forgotten and um anyone
here who is new thank you for for being
here I know how it can be like coming
into the new space and just uh wondering
like do they really want me here and U
we do we're really really glad that
you're that you're here Among Us so
thank you thank you for being with us so
um this is we're entering into the
season of Advent which is great for
those um
unfamiliar Advent is it's not exactly
the same as Christmas um per se so
Christmas obviously is the day Christ is
born um Advent is like the season of um
preparation of um longing for the
arrival of God in the world the arrival
of Christ in the world and the way that
translates kind of into the here now is
like the arrival of um of the spirit in
Christ uh in in my own life in my own
heart and mind um so that's kind of what
we'll be doing in these Sundays uh
leading up to uh up to Christmas and um
so with that in mind um the title of my
message this first Sunday in Advent is
waiting waiting and we've got um kind of
these prescribed readings one thing I
like about Advent is We join in kind of
with the broader um Church you know
globally who's also um observing this
season and so there's like certain they
call it the lectionary like certain
prescribed readings so I have you know
like four five options or so to like
choose from uh and so I kind of like it
kind of forces me into like a certain
Lane um and it's cool because there's so
many you know hundreds of thousands of
other churches like preaching on you
know they got four options too um so our
our prophetic reading this week is from
Isaiah 64 uh verses 1-9 a little bit
lengthy but it's very kind of poetic um
lots of like metaphors and imagery and
um it's a lot going on so you can kind
of follow along um in your Bibles or on
the screen says oh the prophet Isaiah
writes oh that you would Ren the heavens
and come down that the mountains would
tremble before you as when fire sets
Twigs Ablaze and causes water to boil
come down to make your name known to
your enemies and cause the Nations to
Quake before you for for when you did
awesome things that we did not expect
you came down and the mountains trembled
before you and you hear he's doing a lot
of emphasis on these mountains trembling
we'll come back to that later because
there's kind of a nod to other parts of
the Bible
there uh oh verse four since ancient
times no one has heard no ear has
perceived no eye has seen any God
besides you who acts on behalf of those
who wait for
him you come to the help of those who
gladly do right who remember your ways
but when we continue to sin against them
in other words against your ways you
were angry how then can we be saved all
of us have become like one who is
unclean all our righteous acts are like
filthy rags we all shrivel up like a
leaf and like the wind our sins sweep us
away no one calls on your name or
strives to lay hold of you for you've
hidden your face from us and have given
us over to our sins and yet Lord yet you
Lord are our father oh we are the clay
You Are The Potter as we just sang about
we are all the work of your hand do not
be angry beyond measure Lord do not
remember our sins forever oh look on us
we pray for we are all your
people so it's pretty clear um in this
text Isaiah believes um that that we
Humanity we need to be saved um you can
see that in verse five he just comes out
and like overtly says it how then can we
be saved so he's it's a pretty bleak
Prospect for him like how then can we be
saved and um I know that that word you
know saved we need to be saved and you
need to get saved you there's like a
certain
resonance and for some people like um
brother's like yeah he's finally
preaching the gospel
um you know get some people to walk this
aisle by the end of the night you know
come forward
um and but it's a it's a good word I
just I know it's become for many of us
it's become a little bit like
religiously kind of hokey um I can even
think of a movie I saw in high school uh
saved which is like poking at kind of um
evangelicalism basically and uh and yeah
I I I think here's but here's the thing
it's like we're I think we're kind of of
two minds on this because at a a deeper
level which is where I really want to
preach from this this um evening on a
deeper level it's funny that like at one
level we're like saved and you know that
language and on another level we all
know that we need to be saved like and
here's what I mean like look at the
world it's a hot
mess right and almost no one dis I mean
it would be the rare person who's like
no I disagree preacher it's awesome
everything out there is just fine you
know like pretty clearly not all right
so we so at one level we're like I don't
know about being saved that language on
a deeper level I think we actually do
resonate with what Isaiah's saying like
he's like we need to be saved and I
think instead of hearing that language
of being like I think we can say like
yeah you're right man we do we do need
to be saved now you can hear where I'm
kind of trying to reframe it a little
bit because where um I think my my
Christian kind of fundamentalist
brothers and sisters have kind of taken
it is often sort of maybe reduced it
shrunk it boiled down what it means to
be saved to something like walking in an
aisle so that your afterlife problem can
be solved basically you know what I mean
like saved means do you want to go to
the bad place of course you don't so
just step forward and you know and it's
sort of it almost becomes like a little
bit of a sales pitch you know of like
um and that I don't know that does
something it it it shrinks it it it goes
from this kind of You Know Rich kind of
yes we need to be saved and like this
very big sense in it kind of you know
not that afterlife's nothing I'm not
saying like there is no after no right
I'm just saying it's it's about so much
more than that so we do we need to be
saved in this kind of Rich you know
sense but it's about so much more than
simply what happens when we die you know
I'm thinking also well yeah but like
what happens
now what what what's happening in the
world now what's happening in our own
hearts and Minds now and honestly in in
a world where the church has just it
just feels like every year that goes by
just increasingly
loses um more of its voice more of its
um moral credibility with
people and to kind of Wag the finger and
tell people you know you need to be
saved I can tell you how to go to heaven
you know it
just for some segment of the population
it still resonates I think for the vast
majority of people we just shrug you
know it's sort of like who are you to
tell me like how to you right so um but
here's the thing I think if we because
of that though as I was kind of alluding
to earlier if we in light of that sort
of shrug off the word lose the word
that's a missed opportunity right
because as I was naming like no at a
deeper level we actually do resonate
with this we do know that we need to be
saved um because as we look at the world
there is there's so much Brokenness and
um heartache I mean I'm thinking from
the war torn buildings of the Gaza Strip
right now to the front lines of the war
in
Ukraine from the existential risks of of
artificial
intelligence which for those in the loop
you can get a little freaked out the
more you find out about it
to Oceans just a wash in
garbage from The Disappearance of coral
reefs to the loss of biodiversity on a
global
scale from the
alcoholism we just keep
quiet to the anger
the violence the abuse we also keep
quiet from the
insecurities that keep us with people
who hurt and
abuse to the mental health disasters
that I mean honestly befall all of us at
some level
like we need to be saved you know
um from the ongoing Injustice of racism
to the the
xenophobia kind of a cultural
imperialism of a mindset that says God
loves America and only
America um that kind of mentality yeah
we we need to be saved I was on H on
that last one I was on Facebook I'm
still on Facebook because I'm almost
40 and
uh just ask the the 20-year-olds and
down in your life and they're like
Facebook yeah I think I started I had
one maybe one point you know haven't
been on it in seven years I'm still on
Facebook so I go on and someone had like
sent me this friend request and I
recognized the last name as like you
know extended family member like I've
never met this person but just i'
recognize the last name and you're like
oh okay this person is kind of in the
you know extended family and uh so I
just checked you know because I didn't
really know her so I just kind of
clicked over you know checked out the
profile and of course right there is the
bio like first thing there at the top of
Facebook and
um it was I was just I was struck it was
so the bio it was so bad it was so it
was tribal and it was um stupid I don't
know it
said like it wasn't actually a bio like
oh this is me and here's you know I mean
it wasn't that it it literally just said
um I wrote it down just to make sure I
get this lacking all profundity it said
if you're not from the USA don't try to
friend me I won't be friends and I was
just like that's your bio like that's of
all the things you could say to
introduce like just so you know you know
and so that it's that kind of and of
course I scrolled down and there in her
feed was like Christian posts you know
what I mean so like I mean apparently
even
Christians need to be saved like we need
to and I don't mean to poke too much to
others like you know I mean it's it's me
too we like we Collective we Humanity
the table like we need to be saved so
like we know this and I think what this
does this knowledge it creates anxiety
tension angst I mean I get to talking
with people I'm if you're like know me
you know if like you hung out with me
you know I'm like well even in my Ser
you can tell I'm kind of like a big idea
person you know so I love to talk about
like all the angst the things that will
make you angsty in the world I love to
talk about all that and I so I
constantly bump up you know like
artificial intelligence like oh do you
want to conversation about that you know
I mean um and so I see this reaction in
people where it's just like there's just
certain things you know know huh I don't
want to go there don't please don't my
anxiety is high enough Brett I don't
need AI worries you know so right so
this is what I'm talking about that
creates right what's that thing there's
that that bad vibe that that anxiety we
might call it you know it's just so it's
there so as religious people as we I
want to kind of bring this back to
Isaiah what what do we do I think
Isaiah's kind of in his poetry I think
he's kind of hitting on a lot of that
anx I me you could feel the an anxiety
in his passage right it's a little bit
kind of
Bleak and you know how then can we be
saved oh that you would have all you
know it's like it's very angsty so I
think he's going to offer us a few
options many of which I would say
there's good in them but we take them
bad
places we interpret and read them in
ways that it becomes very unhelpful
towards the end of the message um I'll
offer something that I think is actually
a better um kind of way from Isaiah um
but let's start with a few kind of
criticisms um okay so we got these bad
vibes we know we need to be saved so
what do we do option one we'll call this
the danger of spiritual
Nostalgia this would be a kind of
constant looking back a looking back
this can be kind of communal um like
back to the good old days do you
remember back when the table first
started I don't know maybe we don't have
enough of Rich history to really look
back too far um I know of churches you
know where you have a big history and
it's sort of like you're just keep
pining away for the good old days you
know or this can be on kind of an
individual level maybe your like
spiritual High Point was high school or
college you just had the best small
group in college or maybe it was like
that last Church 15 years ago it's like
that's where the spirit was you know and
so what do you do you kind of deal with
the anxiety by constantly looking back
like back to what God used to do back to
the good old days oh if only I could get
back there the all of the problems of of
my world and myself and the broader
world it would be solved like that's
that's what we need back what was in the
past uh I think that you kind of see
this um in The Echoes I was referencing
from Isaiah so there's Echoes In this
passage of Exodus um Exodus
1917-19 so give this a listen imagine um
it's Moses there at the mountain about
to go up to receive the Ten Commandments
is kind of the the cont context then
Moses led the people out of the camp to
meet with God they stood at the foot of
the mountain Mount Si was covered with
smoke because the Lord descended on it
in fire the smoke billowed up from it
like smoke from a furnace and the whole
Mountain trembled
violently as the sound of the trumpet
grew louder and louder Moses spoke and
the voice of God answered him so now let
me go back to is and just listen for the
like resonance starting verse one oh
that you would Ren the heavens and come
down can you hear what he's hoping for
oh that the mountains would tremble
before you as when fire sets Twigs of
Blaze and causes water to boil come down
to make your name known to your enemies
cause the Nations to Quake before you
for when you did awesome things this is
looking backwards right past tense for
when you did awesome things that we did
not expect you came down
and the mountains trembled before you
right can you hear the kind of resonance
between those two passages what I'm
suggesting is Isaiah is looking back
he's remembering those times of old
remembering what God did in the past now
to be fair of course that can be good
you know we can kind of draw strength
for today by remembering God's
faithfulness and the beauty of that
right of course but I'm also suggesting
there is a certain danger there
that we end up always looking back not
to draw strength for the day but just to
Pine away for oh do you remember when
the Lord was really moving you know and
and and what what do we end up missing
we spend so much time looking back we
aren't present to what God is doing
when
now
no right
that's that's the thing and that's the
spirit of Advent right is about what is
the Lord up to right now all right
there's a second danger though we'll
call this the danger of
revivalism this would be um like if
Nostalgia is kind of that looking back
revivalism is looking where ahead
forward to like the future
um here's again this is again verse
three this time I want you to hear not
so much The Exodus part but like the
Epic Grand nature of it all uh again
verse one oh that you would run the
heavens and come down that those
mountains would tremble before you as
when fire sets Twigs of Blaze and causes
water to boil come down to make your
name known to your enemies cause the
Nations to Quake before you for when you
did awesome things epic things amazing
things that we did not expect you came
down and the mountains trembled before
you you might be able to tell from my
preaching style I grew up Charis
medic not Pentecostal we were you know
Pentecostal they were like a little
little too full of the spirit for the
Charisma I don't know we were like one
step over we were like in our hearts we
were Pentecostals like you know secretly
U so what I've noticed kind of coming
from that World by the way I got all of
the good from that um tribe that that
that wing of the church um like in it
just sort of in expectant like sense of
God's presence like God could break
through at any time you know um so I got
all the good I also got all the baggage
and um I've had to work through that
some of one and this is what I'm hitting
all right the danger of not Revival by
the way which we'll kind of get to but
revivalism the danger of revivalism is
this sort of
chronic um we are just
one one fast away just one prayer
service away just one good worship set
away from a move of the spirit that will
shake this church and shake this land
and change everything but it's not yet
it's not
yet it's we we are
forever waiting for
it we're just any minute you know it's
almost like an advent that never gets to
Christmas you know it's a Linton season
that never gets to Easter it's just sort
of like like oh and if we just fast hard
enough and pray long enough and dig deep
enough you know then it's going to
happen I mean for for those who come
from that tradition like you you know
exactly what I'm talking about hopefully
there others you are kind of picking up
on it um and oh and I was a part late
90s early 2000s I was a part of the like
the movement that where kind of became
like Revival even what it meant wasn't a
surprising move of the grace and
goodness of God that would like of just
an outpouring of God's love on us and
our enemies you know no no Revival
basically boiled down to getting our
preferred political candidates into
power and then through that sort of
nudging America towards the theocracy
that was basically like you know what
Revival came
to yeah um this becomes problematic or
whatever your vision of Revival um not
because again that the spirit can't
break through of course God can do
anything um but but it becomes danger we
get in that revivalism mindset this it's
it's forever deferred forever um kind of
on its way and again what do we miss
when we do that we
miss that I mean since the pouring out
of the Holy Spirit In the book of Acts
Revival is always here and
available the holy spirit is here and
available to each and every every one of
you
today right now like God is breaking
through or wants to all we have to do is
just say yes like yes Lord you know it's
it doesn't have to be this pining away
for oh if only something epic could
happen in the
future um our third our third one um
this is kind of a cousin of revivalism
we'll call it the danger of toxic
holiness
um so again not Holiness Holiness is
good um but kind of a toxic Holiness
which is um basically a the reason
either the good old days aren't here or
the reason revival terries is because
you all are so
bad you know that's sort of toxic
Holiness like and and suddenly church
becomes um boot camp and the pastor is
the drill sergeant you know where it's
sort of like clean up your act and then
a Revival will come and then the Lord
will come and then you know then all the
good things will happen um I think you
see kind of um this is where the
Pharisees went of course in the New
Testament and I wonder if in ways they
were drawing at least from a certain
reading or interpretation of Isaiah
64 um you you might have heard it
earlier so we'll read it again verse
five you come to the help of those who
gladly do right who remember your ways
but when we continued to sin against
them you were
angry it's a key word you're
angry how then can we be saved all of us
have become like one who's unclean all
our righteous acts are like filthy rags
we all shrivel up like a leaf and like
the wind our sins sweep us away no one
calls on your name or strives to lay
hold of you for you've hidden your face
from us and have given us over to our
sins you can kind of hear in that you
know a certain kind of um bemoaning you
know um so here's the thing um what I
deeply appreciate about Isaiah though
and all this even for all my my my
gentle push backs and you know um if not
on Isaiah at least our readings and
interpretations of Isaiah what I
appreciate about him is his heart here I
think he has a heart hungering for God
he has a heart he's he's dealing with
the anxiety that we all deal with and
he's in his own poetic way he's longing
for the more that each of of us need and
I think there's a number of moments in
this passage that that it's I noticed
them because they seemed so nonanxious
much of what he's writing here seems
very anxious to me but there's a few
moments of
like everyone
say it's nice huh is that nice I think
we see that um in verse four and then
again verse eight he says since ancient
times no one has heard no ear has
perceived no I has seen any God besides
you you who acts on behalf of those who
wait for him in verse eight and yet you
Lord are our father oh we are the clay
You Are The Potter and we are all the
work of your hand notice who is doing
the work here in those
verses it's it's God
it's
God that that's what I love like I think
we get so in our head about like I've
got to make it
happen and instead
of knowing it is God who will do it and
what I have to do is say
yes yes like that's the heart of advent
is
just receiving like it's not getting out
there in the world and like changing
everything and everyone for Jesus you
know um although that can be there can
be a good heart behind that um but it's
go out there in the world and say yes
and be open and understand like God is
already doing it you are not the Potter
I am not the
Potter the Lord Jesus is the Potter and
we are the
clay and I to that I say praise be to
God
um God who is pick your metaphor a
faithful mother a good father The God
Who is Love The God Who is faithful and
Christ is here with us now through the
spirit is here with us now doing his
good work and so we don't need to be
obsessed over another's
sins as though God could Hinder or as
though that could hinder the work of God
in us like no no no no God is the Potter
we are the clay that's the heart of
Advent it's an expectant waiting it's a
watchfulness as the desert fathers and
mothers would have put it it's a heart
posture of prayer it's
attention to the
Lord as uh Rowan Williams the Theologian
writes he says our problem in
prayer 99 times out of a 100 is not the
absence of God but the absence of who
me it's me I am anywhere and everywhere
but here God as it were sits patiently
in my here while I am
there and I guess this is the irony of
Isaiah 64 I he's Isaiah's very worked up
here he like oh Lord if only you could
be be here now breaking through if only
the good old days could happen if only
Revival could happen if only all these
people would clean up their act you know
oh Lord if only you could be here now
and God what is God saying God is saying
oh I'm
here I'm here Isaiah I'm here church
it's you who's gone out for a
walk it's you who's gone who's not
waiting for me not attuned to
me not
open to
me to kind of draw on all the nature
metaphors um In this passage we might
just put it like this to wait is to
allow ourselves to
be the clay molded by the Potter The
Twig set a light by The Flame the
mountain set trembling by the earthquake
the withered leaf given New Life by The
Vine that's the invitation of Advent and
I think this is what this is
what Nostalgia and revivalism and toxic
Holiness misses it's just not about our
striving or our wishing or our
[Music]
longings no no it's about God it's about
God and it is about us in the sense of
and our own willingness to say
yes
yes I think of the story from uh Samuel
Speak Lord your servant is
listening that's the heart posture of
Advent it's just a simple
yes so that's what we wait for in this
season the arrival of Christ in the
world the arrival of Christ in our own
heart and mind in the name of the Father
the Son and the Holy Spirit spirit
amen so as we uh as we come to the table
of the Lord tonight as we take in the
body of Christ in the bread the blood of
Christ in the
wine may it be a nonanxious moment of
just receiving you know some of you I
know you come in here you feel well it's
again the world needs to be saved we
need to be saved right so we just feel
all beaten up and there's all sorts of
crap going on everyone
like all the time perpetually you know
and so we come here and it's not oh God
if only maybe you could no no it's it's
a receiving you take in Christ you take
in God into your very
being just just receive that's kind of
the heart posture I hope you can partake
of communion tonight you just take take
it in um so the way we'll receive the
body um and the blood of Jesus tonight
is we just kind of do it row by row so
we'll start here at the front and we
will work our way back um we practiced
what's called an Open Table meaning if
you're here tonight and you'd like to
participate then you just go right on
ahead regardless of your exact
denomination or you know whatever um we
don't have like the theological police
here you know um the red is wine the
white is grape juice and then um finally
you can just partake whenever you'd like
so immediately you can return to your
seat but no one will like lead you
through the exact you know moment of
taking the elements so this is the
table not of the church not of the
church but of the Lord and it's made
ready for those who love him and for
those who want to love him more so
come you who have much faith and you who
have
little you who have been here often and
you who have not been here long you who
have try to follow and you have just
failed at least you feel like you failed
you just come
because it's the Lord Jesus who invites
you and it's his will that those who
want to meet him should meet him here
come to the
[Music]
table
she
[Music]
for
as you finish taking your communion if
you would like to stand and sing this
song with us the chorus is very easy to
catch on to it's still kind of a newer
song for our community but um the
message in the heart of it is just about
um entering into the peace of God and
speaking that over one another um just a
blessing of peace and and as Brett was
talking about kind of our tendency
towards anxiety and fear and um I was
just think about how such a beautiful
way to end our time together tonight is
just to speak out peace and um wanting
to step out into that Spirit into that
practice as we leave this space together
and carry that into our weeks so you
guys feel free to sing along from your
chair or if you would like to stand with
[Music]
us
theace of the Lord
[Music]
of
you to the
wild he give you
the through the
[Music]
days theace of the Lord go with you may
theace of the Lord go with
you
whereever you may
[Music]
go show
Jo
[Music]
you hold
you when you meet your Fe
[Music]
to the go with
you the to the go with you may
theace of the Lord go with
you
wherever you
[Music]
go this message I think it's just such a
beautiful reminder that we don't have to
have it together um God doesn't call us
to be
perfect um he calls us to come as we are
so I think that was very encouraging and
beautiful to to hear and be reminded
of um I want to thank you all for being
here with us this evening if you are new
um or just gener generally would love to
you know learn more about the table and
what we stand for I encourage you to
scan that code or you can fill out one
of the cards out in the foyer um just
for us to get to know you better send
you a thank you for visiting and answer
any questions that you might have if
you're in need of a hug uh high five of
prayer or just encouragement in general
feel free to come find me after service
I'll be over here um find Brett or
really anyone else would' be happy to
give that to you U so here at the table
we
are we are very encouraged and we want
to uh be able to provide everything that
we can to you all um and be a you know
continue to grow as a community and do
what we can to service you all and the a
key component to that is
generosity so if you feel led to give I
encourage you to again scan that QR code
behind me or you can fill out a card in
the foyer to do
so I'm going to go ahead and send us off
with the benediction um I always say
it's near and dear to my heart um feel
free to receive this uh with a posture
of receiving close your eyes just let
these words flow over you and through
you you are a child of God you are a
child of God this is true on your best
day and this is true on your worst day
so as you go into your week ahead with
it's yet to be determined highs and lows
and everything in between go filled with
the assurance that you are loved you you
are worthy and you are accepted just the
way that you are and go filled with
God's Holy Spirit and the desire to
extend these same Gifts of Grace of
unconditional love to everyone that you
come in contact with be blessed see you
next Sunday and don't forget about hat
Creek uh tonight if you want to join us
thank
you
[Music]
May the peace of the Lord go with
you May the peace of the Lord go with
you